[music playing]
NARRATOR: Paracas
skull number 44.
Discovered in 2012, it has
a weight of 2.8 pounds--
25% heavier than the
average adult male skull.
It has a cranial capacity
of 1,500 cubic centimeters--
20% greater than normal.
And it is missing
a sagittal suture,
the connective
tissue joint found
between the parietal
bones in all human skulls.
This is just one of hundreds
of strange, misshapen skulls
that have been found on
the southern coast of Peru,
dating back to 1927.
It was at this time that
archaeologist Julio Tello first
excavated a massive burial
complex thought to have been
built by the Paracas people, who
lived in the region from 800 BC
to 100 BC.
Julio C. Tello was the
father of Peruvian archeology.
And in the 1920s, he
discovered mummy bundles.
And in each mummy bundle was a
person with an elongated skull.
They were buried in
family mausoleums,
in some cases as deep as
30 feet into the bedrock.
NARRATOR: Mainstream
archaeologists
say the elongation is most
likely the result of head
binding, which involves
wrapping the heads of infants
while their skulls
are still soft
in order to change the shape.
It is a practice found
in numerous cultures
throughout the world that
dates back thousands of years.
But why would people
desire to elongate
the heads of their children?
Ancient astronaut theorists
suggest that head binding
originated with
primitive humans who
were attempting to
imitate the appearance
of extraterrestrial visitors.
But according to
researcher Brian Foerster,
the assistant director of
the Paracas History Museum,
head binding would not account
for the other anomalies
that the Paracas skulls exhibit.
About 5% of the elongated
skulls that we find in Paracas
are so complex in shape
and size that it's
hard to believe that
they're the result
of any form of cranial
deformation or head binding.
Not only are they
elongated vertically,
but also the eye sockets
are much larger than normal.
There are two holes in
the back of the skull
called foramen through which
blood and nerve flow occurred.
And also their jaws
were very robust.
And among the
largest of them, we
find skulls 60% heavier than
normal human skulls and a brain
capacity that is
2.5 times larger
than the normal human brain.
NARRATOR: But if these
elongated skulls were not
the result of the ancient
practice of head binding,
then just who or what were
these mysterious beings?
In 2014, DNA testing
was performed
on Paracas skull
number 44, which
rendered surprising results.
Some initial DNA
testing has been done.
And the results according
to the geneticists
are quite startling.
There were certain segments
of the DNA that didn't match
anything known to be human.
What it suggests to me is
that Paracas could very well
have been an ancient bloodline
related to Homo sapiens
but not specifically
Homo sapiens itself.
When you look at this kind
of archaeological evidence,
you're seeing
concrete, tangible,
DNA-testable proof
that extraterrestrials
walked on Earth right among us.